hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called Triple
R spoilers ahead watch out and stay safe
the film opens with a woman named
Catherine having her hand painted by
Mali a talented young girl from the gone
tribe meanwhile her husband Scott Buxton
an oppressive British administrator is
returning from a hunting trip in the
forest Catherine really likes the
painting on her hand and Scott is
astounded that such a young girl has
such talent Scott despises the people of
the tribe and doesn't care about their
existence in fact he considers them to
be inferior Catherine tells her husband
that she wants to take the little girl
with them Scott then orders his
assistant Edward to compensate the
girl's parents Loki the mother doesn't
understand their language and assumes
that the payment is for her daughter's
Talent what she doesn't get is that her
daughter is being taken away the little
girl is brought to a car and Loki chases
after them screaming desperately Loki
tries to stop the car and clings to the
window looking tearfully at his daughter
then Loki begs them to let his daughter
go but a soldier approach and puts a gun
to her head Scott prevents him from
shooting her because he doesn't want him
to waste the bullet so the soldier takes
a piece of wood and hits her in the head
the rest of the clan can only stand
there dumbfounded in the process the
little girl watches the cruelty and is
taken away the scene shifts to a crowd
of enraged Rebels who are on the verge
of raiding a prison facility to demand
the freedom of their leader Lala latch
Pat Rai the prison guards are
outnumbered and use primitive weapons so
they are terrified the officer in charge
asks for assistance but is told it will
be hours before reinforcements arrive
the fence is about to collapse and one
of the rebels throws a stone hitting
Scott buxton's picture the officer in
charge instructs a soldier named Raju to
arrest the protester who did it given
the thousands of irate protesters
outside the task seems impossible
however without thinking he dives into
the crowd and starts punching everyone
in an attempt to catch the culprit as a
result he is overpowered and even hit in
the head with a stone but he doesn't
give up he breaks the hand of a rebel
and then hits others with his stick in
the process the culprit tries to escape
but finds no way out the soldier runs up
a tower which then collapses due to the
rebels who continue to climb it he then
finds himself surrounded again and
pushes the rebels off a cliff killing
them later he spots the culprit in the
crowd and chases him he grabs him by the
arm and despite being overpowered
several times manages to take him to the
commander successfully everyone is
Amazed by his abilities and even the
rebels are now terrified and running
away in the next scene we witness a
ceremony during which the three best
officers of the year are chosen Raju is
visibly outraged when he realizes he was
not chosen however he continues to train
hard the action shifts to venkat a
special advisor to the nizam he wishes
to meet with governor Scott but since
the latter is unavailable he informs his
assistant Edward of the reason for his
visit Nally was kidnapped by Scott and
his team now both the tribe and the
police department want her back then cat
informs Edward that the tribe has a
guardian willing to do the impossible to
safeguard the girl subtly threatening
him the scene shifts to a forest a man
named B-Max is bait to catch a wolf that
is tormenting the clan the wolf begins
to chase him and as he flees beam spots
tracks left by a tiger shortly after the
tiger comes out of hiding and chases him
the man manages to trick the two animals
into colliding against each other the
tiger defeats the wolf and then sets out
again and beams footsteps he lures the
Predator into a trap and manages to
capture it with the help of his men for
the record beam is the feared Guardian
mentioned by the nizam special advisor
he and his men have been searching for
the kidnapped girl for the past six
months but have been unsuccessful next
beam disguises himself as a Muslim
technician and returns to town a British
soldier brings him his motorcycle and
indignantly states that he hasn't
repaired it properly beam teaches him
how to start it and a woman starts
laughing Furious the British soldier
beats him severely but beam refuses to
fight back because he doesn't want his
identity revealed moreover he wants to
make sure that the family that provides
him with a home is not in injured
meanwhile Edward rounds up the soldiers
and orders them to identify the dreaded
Clan guardian and capture him Catherine
states that whoever can do the
impossible will be promoted to the rank
of special officer the commander says
they can entrust the mission to Raju and
he accepts the challenge later Roger
talks to his colleague and states that
there is no need to search the whole
city because the guardian will come to
them alone he also suggests that the
police pretend to be on his side so that
they can trap and capture him beam and
his men study how to gain access to the
governor's residence he sends one of his
cronies djangu to pose as a worker Jang
who is beaten as soon as he is caught
without papers Jenny the governor's
niece scolds the soldier for treating
the worker inhumanely Jenny helps djangu
and lets him go beam devises a plan to
gain entry by befriending Jenny Raju
attends a meeting of pro-independence
rebels in hopes of discovering
information that might lead them to beam
he wants to make the tribal Chief
believe that they are fighting for the
same cause as a result the tribal Chief
will loosen his guard Raju even proposes
to assassinate governor Scott his plan
works because Bean's brother lachu Falls
for it latu secretly approaches Raju
telling him that he and his brother also
want to kill the governor ruja asks him
to take him to his brother and lachu
agrees they run into a roadblock and
Roger Whispers that he is an officer
telling him to let them pass the
policeman returns with the papers and
gives Raju a military salute lachu
realizes it is a trap and runs away Raju
chases after him but soon after lachu
gets mixed up in a crowd of people a
little later lachu catches up with beam
and his friends he reveals that there is
an officer pretending to be on their
side who has almost been arrested Dean
tells him to hide and not to be seen
around town maju and his uncle are
considering their next action after
failing to arrest lachu in the meantime
beam and his companions are hiding just
below them suddenly a Wandering
bystander catches fire and falls into
the water and boy begs for help as the
fire is about to engulf him beam and
Roger decide to work together to rescue
the boy bringing the mission to a
success blend as time passes the two
grow closer and closer one day Raju is
about to analyze the sketch of the
person he was looking for unfortunately
the sketch Falls before beam can examine
it this would reveal to him that the
person he is hunting is indeed his new
friend Roger then assists beam in wooing
Jenny unaware of his plan to infiltrate
Scott's house as they Converse Jenny
mentions mali's name and claims that the
girl resides with them veeam is left
speechless he then proceeds to give the
girl a gift Jenny asks beam to attend a
party after a dance battle beam is
invited to Jenny's house at that point
he realizes that Mali is really inside
and is being held captive she begs him
to take her home immediately but this
means that both of them will be arrested
finally he promises to free her and
leaves meanwhile Roger pursues and
captures lachu so that he can reveal to
him who his brother is during the
process lachu throws a deadly snake at
Raju who is consequently bitten lachu
warns him of his impending doom and
informs him that the antidote is known
only to the Gans soon after Roger
reaches beam who immediately takes care
of him after noticing similarities in
the religious accessories between beam
and lachu Raju finally discovers the
truth deem is completely unaware of
raju's hidden identity and confesses his
tribal Origins and Mission Dean's men
break into Governor Scott's house with a
truck full of various animals to create
Panic among the party guests as the
animals charge Scott's guards beam
fights some of them then beam gets Jenny
to safety and in the process Raju
appears dressed in full military Garb
theme is surprised because he had no
idea that Raju was a British police
officer Roger arrest beam despite his
pleas not to do so because his only goal
is to save Mali beam refuses to be
Chained and the two fight until Raju
finally gets the upper hand after the
incident Raju arrests beam and is
promoted to a higher rank but he feels
guilty about his conduct remembering his
pro-nationalist past and his real Alter
Ego as a police mole the governor
expresses his gratitude to Raju he then
orders him to punish Bean to prevent
another attack on the British Catherine
wishes to see blood and the governor
chooses to publicly flog beme as
punishment citizens of the surrounding
region are encouraged to participate in
the public flogging after the flogging
begins Catherine is shocked as despite
the torture beam does not bleed next
Raju is given a spiked whip Roger tries
to encourage him to apologize for his
behavior he wants beam to confess his
sins but Bean prefers to be wept despite
excruciating pain from his injuries beam
sings in defiance inciting the audience
to revolt the Revolt eventually
enlightens Raju who realizes the Folly
of his actions Raju informs his uncle of
his plan to rescue beam in free melee he
also tells how beam song was able to
inspire hundreds of people a few days
later the governor wants to have beam
executed Roger recommends hanging him in
front of Mali because after all he is
here for her Roger goes on to say that
he should not be hanged in public
because he would be remembered as a hero
on the contrary Raju wishes for him to
be executed somewhere away from the eyes
of the pub public this way they can also
dispose of his body in secret module
begins to work out his plan to save Mali
as the crew approaches the execution
site meanwhile he is seriously injured
but Mali manages to escape Into the
Wilderness Raju shoots the policemen who
approach him after hearing the gunshots
beam starts fighting the officers
guarding him then he sees Raju coming
and thinks he wants to kill Mali so he
hits him violently in the face he then
hits him again and runs away with Mali
the authorities are Now intent on
capturing beam again the government
offers cash rewards for his capture and
posters are put up throughout the city
meanwhile despite being days away from
execution Roger remains stubborn and
continues to strengthen his force in the
meantime Colonial officials Corner beam
and Mali they are seconds away from
being arrested as one of the police
officers enters the room where they are
hiding Sita raju's girlfriend pretends
that the people inside are suffering
from a contagious disease this causes
the police officer to flee when he
informs his boss everyone is told to
leave the house without understanding
who beam is the woman reveals raju's
true anti-colonial goals and his
impending death beam pledges to defend
him after realizing that it was his
fault as he believed Raju was attacking
Mali he promises Sita that he will do
everything to save raju's Life theme
infiltrates the barracks where Raju is
being held he frees him alarming
numerous soldiers beam has to carry Raju
on his shoulders because of his leg
injuries the two then fight the soldiers
who try to prevent him from escaping the
two managed to escape into a nearby
Forest the governor is informed of these
and he orders the Special Forces to
eliminate the escapes Raju and beam
Slaughter other soldiers in the nearby
jungle using a longbow stolen from a ram
Shrine Raju also uses an arrow to throw
grenades and Slaughter other soldiers at
one point Bean carries a motorcycle with
his hands and throws it toward the
soldiers he then confronts and kills
Edward the governor's assistant as the
soldiers are being slaughtered the two
run toward the barracks where governor
Scott is waiting for them they are
greeted by cannons but Raju and beam are
unstoppable Roger's signals beam to take
his motorcycle and ride it toward the
barracks Raju fires an arrow while in
the air setting the motorcycle on fire
when it crashes into the ammunition
storage Barracks it catches fire and
explodes killing Catherine and the
soldiers the film ends with governor
Scott badly wounded and confronted by
Raju and beam Raju shoots him with an
arrow and beam completes the killing
with an English weapon subscribe and hit
that like button to help our Channel
grow turn the notifications on so you
won't miss any of our new videos thanks
for watching